so I want to ask you a little bit about
you and Christian because we now have
seen you guys be together on the show
but tell me more about your relationship
before the show how did you meet and how
long had you been together we met
through Catherine agro because Christian
is her roommate another bachelor nation
alone yes so we met through her and we
were just two humans enjoying each
other's company I'd always known that I
was gonna go on paradise and so I was up
front with her about that whenever we
first met so we both agreed to keep it
open not exclusive well that's what I
was wondering because when she came to
paradise you seemed really happy to see
each other and it didn't give an
indication that you'd had a bad breakup
or something did you actually breakup
before you went to paradise or were you
in an exclusive thing we were never
really together so there was nothing to
breakup it was just like I'm open I'm
still gonna be open I could go to
paradise and I might fall in love with
someone and you like she was okay with
that but yeah so whenever I saw her I
had no idea that the feelings were so
strong until like we were finally like
reunited did you have any idea that she
might show up in paradise no I thought I
was leaving I thought that Christmas
taking me up there to say all right go
get her go get her like home for Nia
because you said I want to talk to Chris
what did you want to say to Chris were
you ready to leave the show I was at the
point where I was ready to leave the
show if that's what my only option was
yeah he's just he's great personally get
advice from you said that when you
started dating Christian you intended to
go on paradise the whole time but if you
were feeling feelings for her why not
just stay what wasn't clicking a hundred
percent about things with Christian I
think it was my fear of commitment
I wasn't ready yet and I didn't know if
that's what I wanted I wanted to protect
myself so I kept it you know very
surface level and didn't really let her
in kept it light yeah that's very late
because then on the show you started to
say to Hanna when she came and also to
Derek wait this is more serious I may
have been downplaying this what was that
realization you're having that I
actually cared about her a lot more than
I thought I did sometimes it's hard to
admit we care
right I know and trying to keep it cool
the whole time and then not being around
her at all and still thinking about her
whenever I'm exploring a relationship
with an amazing man
it was confusing for me but
I mean it is amazing he's the best isn't
he he really is I mean when you look
back tell me about that breakup moment
with him how hard that was oh my gosh
that was one of the hardest things ever
had to do because I didn't want to hurt
anybody but the way that he responded it
just went to prove how me singing is
respectful King yeah sure
I Dirac now has this rallying cry people
wanting him to be the bachelor you know
where do you fall on that I will support
him whatever he wants to do I just want
him to be happy but are you gonna
campaign for that like Darren I'm here
for you I mean you tweet a lot are you
on the derek for bachelor hashtag train
well you know I'm just trying to like
get through paradise and you know there
it's still on paradise true though you
know have you talked to him do you know
if he's found love I've talked to Derek
but we don't talk about our love life
together anymore we just like to keep it
fun
okay is it still a little weird I mean
cuz you did day yeah I don't think it's
weird I just think that it's easier
whenever we're just talking like making
jokes and stuff giving it life yes give
it a minute like keeping it funny making
sure we're good
[Music]